bueno yo quiero contarles que hace unos
meses en un intento desesperado por
empatar con mis compañeras de hogar mi
rutina de reciclaje y de composta pegue
coloque en el bote de basura más usado
en nuestra casa una duda genuina y
espontánea que es basura
esta pregunta que es basura fue un
resumen de todo un debate interno que ya
traía desde hace tiempo
resumió ahora así que todos los
cuestionamientos que tenía alrededor
sobre el tema
quiero contarles que todas estas dudas
nacen rastreando un poco tienen su
origen porque mi mamá
desde siempre ha dicho que la basura de
unas personas es el tesoro de otras
personas y mis padres también desde muy
pequeños en conjunto a mis hermanos ya
mí nos enseñaron a apilar nuestros
cuadernos al final de cada ciclo escolar
ya llevarlos a las recicladoras de mis
tíos a mi abuelo también desde que
recuerdo junta objetos muy peculiares de
los desechos de otras personas
literalmente se para en la calle abre
bolsas le fascinan las cosas que
encuentra y se las lleva a su casa para
emplearlas nuevamente
yo he tenido por lo tanto que ser muy
cuidadosa para no ser una acumulador
compulsiva y también me gusta ir hurgar
un poco en la basura vecina con la
esperanza de que la basura esté separada
lo que más quisiera que la basura
estuviera en orgánica e inorgánica me
encontrado desde retratos fotografías
que vale la pena restaurar bueno
cualquier fotografía valdría la pena
restaurarla
también he encontrado cajas huacales es
lo que más me encuentro y rescato de la
calle he encontrado dvds cds y bueno
infinidad de piezas que puedo volver a
emplear
pero ahora ya siendo más consciente de
que no quiero acumular antes de recoger
la basura o los desechos
me detengo y me soy muy sincera me gusta
preguntarme ahora cuánto tiempo es que
va a pasar para que yo pueda limpiar ese
objeto y emplearlo en mi vida
y yo me dedico profesionalmente y de
forma cotidiana a la fotografía y al
vídeo
tengo que hacer principalmente
dos actividades dos acciones principales
tanto en foto como en vídeo que son
curar y espirar la imagen curar lo hago
al momento de seleccionar hago una
primera selección y espirar lo hago en
el segundo momento cuando después de esa
primera selección tengo que estar
todavía más cuidadosa fijarme los
detalles y ver lo que no vi en la
primera lectura de la imagen y esta
misma fórmula he buscado trasladarla a
mis hábitos de consumo porque si
solamente una tercera parte de
lo que yo de la basura que yo genero es
reciclable
entonces
tengo que pensar que lo que sigue por
hacer
quizás no sea reciclar quizás sea
reutilizar o
o quizás e incluso dejar de consumir
ciertas cosas reducir mi consumo pues
méxico es el país de américa latina que
más basura produce este es un dato de
banco mundial así como una predicción
que hace banco mundial es que para 2050
la basura que generamos se duplique
nosotros actualmente estamos generando
como 700
gramos de basura por día por persona
entonces para 2050 vamos a generar algo
así como un kilo y medio de basura si
contamos toda esta basura a lo largo de
un año la basura cada uno de ustedes si
cada uno de ustedes junta su basura a lo
largo de un año en una habitación de
aproximadamente 2 x 2 la llena
pero lo que hacemos es colocarlas
colocar los desechos en bolsas
trasladarlos luego a recipientes donde
todo lo que estamos desechando y
consumiendo no se ve y encima
se lo damos a personas que no conocemos
personas de las que tampoco sabemos nada
no sabemos nada sobre la vida de los
recolectores de basura de los
transportistas
tampoco sabemos nada sobre la vida de
los pepenadores
la cantidad de frutas y verduras que
nosotros no comemos el pedacito que
queda por ejemplo de el jitomate todo
eso finalmente no regresa a la tierra y
es muy poco probable que en algún
momento lo haga
aquí hay otro dato que quiero
compartirles que es que la secretaria de
medio ambiente y recursos naturales
semarnat aqui en mexico tiene pensado
que solamente el 13% de los basureros
son rellenos sanitarios y el 87% el
restante
son tiraderos a cielo abierto entonces
la basura también es un tema de salud
pública
yo me pregunto en este punto
si de alguna manera cada uno de nosotros
y nosotros en conjunto podemos
dignificar el trabajo por ejemplo de los
pepenadores y de toda la gente que se
encarga de nuestros desechos inegi tiene
censados
aqui en mexico 241 centros de acopio de
distintos materiales como es plástico
pet aluminio cartón papel
de unicel y de vidrio oscuro hay muy
pocos en méxico y son específicos y
están centralizados hay muy pocos por
ejemplo en la ciudad de mexico
por lo tanto es muy complicado trasladar
el unicel y es costoso también
darle
el procedimiento adecuado pues para
poder reutilizarlos
para poder convertirlo en otra cosa pues
hace unas semanas conocí a marín marín
es mi vecino y vivimos en el mismo
barrio
fin
a diferencia de mi vive en la calle
marín se dedica a pepenar
yo me acerco con él y me acompaña a mi
casa para darle unas botellas unas latas
perdón de aluminio que junté en el ínter
estamos platicando un poco yo desde el
principio quise sacar la cámara la
grabadora preguntarle porque estaba en
la calle cuál era su situación actual
que me contara acerca de su vida pues
pero marín fue que empezó con el
bombardeo de preguntas
a mari le parecía muy sorprendente que
la comunicóloga junto a las latas
[Música]
mari me hizo una de las preguntas más
no solo laboralmente que me han hecho
sino en general en la vida
y aquí lo parafraseó un poco pero va en
el mismo sentido de su pregunta
marín me pregunta de qué les sirve tu
profesión al mundo tu por qué te dedicas
a lo que te dedicas al mundo a las
personas a la gente no a la industria a
la tierra de que le eres útil
a partir de aquí empezó otro tipo de
reflexión
me dije a mí
me di cuenta que estar viviendo de cerca
todos estos procesos a lo largo de mi
vida con mi familia ahora estas charlas
que he tenido con marín porque ya se
volvieron que nos encontramos y hablamos
de personajes muy variados no hablamos
desde timbiriche hasta thomas alva
edison estas estas charlas con marín con
mi abuelo con mi mamá en general en mi
vida
me han llevado a esta serie de
reflexiones entonces yo de pronto estoy
frente a un aparador lleno de plásticos
dentro de esos plásticos hay pura azúcar
y en ese momento yo digo casi en voz
alta que no quiero ser partícipe y no
puedo ser partícipe de una industria que
no se preocupa ni se ocupa por a dónde
van sus desechos de una industria que
encima tampoco
se preocupa por el consumidor por el
bienestar ni por la salud del consumidor
pero la verdad es que luego al día
siguiente oa los dos días o quizás en
ese mismo momento
abro ese mismo refrigerador y consumo el
embotellado lleno de azúcar y es que así
de complejos y victoriosos somos
y no tenemos la culpa tenemos quizás y
la responsabilidad pero tampoco es una
responsabilidad directa sobre sobre un
daño y bueno no quiero dejarlos a este
punto de la charla que se fue mucho ya
bombardeó
he pensado cuáles son nuestras opciones
que nos corresponde hacer nos
corresponde hacer algo a nosotros como
consumidores
o es solamente a la producción la
industria quién tendría que
reestructurar a reestructurarse perdón
al sería que en las ciudades que cada
cada uno de nosotros
dejando de consumir los potes de
plástico pues en realidad pudiéramos
lograr un impacto mayor sobre la tierra
esas acciones cuentan pero estas
acciones son individuales y son muy
mínimas y esas acciones por lo tanto no
tejen de forma comunitaria y lo que
necesitamos entonces es fijar una
postura una postura que vaya más allá de
de decirle no al popote una postura que
sea de rechazo una postura que sea de
desconocimiento ante un panorama mundial
de causa esta postura puede fijar un
contrapeso es ya un contrapeso pensarnos
como nos estamos pensando actualmente
que de lo que hago a dónde va como le
repercute a otras personas y a otros
seres vivos
esa postura
puede lograr una serie de acciones no
aisladas que en conjunto y
comunitariamente puede impactar de otra
forma entonces nos toca exigir nos toque
exigir una política ambiental nos toque
involucrarnos en una política ambiental
porque sin ella simplemente no podemos
abogar ni siquiera por hechos humanos ni
por derechos animales
y este mundo así lo amerita así lo
necesita un mundo en donde la calidad
del aire y del agua óptimas
pues son la base para cualquier ser vivo
y bueno los invito a que nos pensemos en
nuestro cotidiano
que de lo que estamos haciendo podemos
dejar de hacer si al día
quizás consumimos tres aguas
embotelladas pues quizás podemos rebajar
la cantidad y nada más consumir una por
ejemplo
gracias
[Aplausos]